Apple's new iPad specific OS or iPad OS
is coming this fall and it's bringing a
bunch of new features that make it more
like a computer than ever before
in this video is a full guide on how to
use the new split view in multitasking
features so let's get started
multitasking starts with the app dock so
let's fill it up with the apps we'll use
every day something new this year is the
ability to put entire app folders onto
the dock so you can have access to any
app you want from just the dock
starting with slide over mode first open
an app then swipe up from the bottom to
bring up the dock then drag an app onto
the side of the screen but don't drag it
to the very edge you can now use both
apps at the same time or drag items from
one app into the other like images links
or files you can also swipe the bar on
the bottom of the slide over window to
switch between other apps you have open
and slide over mode or you can swipe up
on that bar to show all of the apps at
once and choose which one you'd like to
use you can also drag the top of the
slide over a window to the other side of
the screen
slide over mode is very useful for doing
things like quickly bringing up the
files app and dragging files into apps
like luma fusion for video editing if
you don't have the desired app open in
one of your slide over windows just drag
the app from the dock and it'll replace
the current app once you're finished
just grab the edge of the window and
swipe it off the screen and you can
swipe again to bring it back to switch
the split view mode just pull the top
bar down and into the edge of the screen
at that point you can bring back the
slide over window by swiping from the
edge you can move it to the other side
just as before and pulling down on the
slide over apps top bar will replace the
underlying split view app you can easily
swap the positions of the apps by
dragging the top bar of an app to the
other side you can also drag the bar in
the center of the apps to give more
space to either app either in a 50/50 or
25/75 split to replace an app while and
split you just drag it from the app dock
you can even use the same app on both
sides of the screen which is useful for
transferring files in the files app and
it should work for third-party apps like
Microsoft Word but it doesn't seem to be
working yet in this first beta of iPad
OS within the Notes app you can even
grab a note and drag it to the side of
the screen to open both notes
side by side while the male app is open
you can compose a new email
and drag the composed view to the side
and either slide over or split view mode
hit cancel or sent and it'll
automatically close the coolest part is
that you can swipe along the bottom of
the screen to swipe between apps and all
the different split view app
combinations you previously had open
will be saved including as many versions
of each app as you'd like you can also
swipe with four fingers instead to
switch between apps or swipe up to get
to the home screen or swipe up and stop
at the center to open the app switcher
and choose the app you want to use if
you want to exit split view mode just
pull down on one of the apps tabs to get
into slide over mode then swipe it off
the screen now let's say you're at the
home screen and you want to start a
fresh version of an app but it keeps
opening up the same app that's already
in split view well simply tap and hold
on an app in the dock or on the home
screen and tap show all windows to open
the app expose from here you'll see the
various versions of the app currently
open and you can swipe to close them or
tap the plus icon to start fresh if you
want to get back to a different version
of the app you're currently using just
tap the same app within the app dock and
it'll open up that same app expose now
in Safari
we finally get automatic desktop mode
for browsing into split view just tap
and hold on a tab and drag it to the
edge of the screen you can also watch
videos in picture-in-picture mode if the
video player supports it by tapping the
pit button you can now swipe between
apps and use your iPad while the video
plays you can tap to pause closed or
bring it back to the Safari window you
can also drag it to any corner of the
screen and spread it with two fingers to
make the video larger you can use pip on
YouTube but it'll only play while the
tab is open and you can't move it around
but it's useful if you want to browse
YouTube Apple is also adding some text
editing features that can really speed
up your workflow you can quickly pick up
your cursor with one finger and move it
around anywhere you'd like or use two
fingers anywhere on the screen you can
also tap multiple times to select
different amounts of text tap twice to
select a word tap three times or for
some reason four times in this beta
version to select a sentence and tap
four times or for us five times to
select an entire paragraph you can then
pinch with three fingers to copy and
then spread with three fingers to paste
to undo you don't have to shake it
more just swipe left with three fingers
and then swipe right with three fingers
to redo and finally you can pinch with
two fingers on the keyboard to shrink it
and then grab the tab to move it
wherever you'd like on the screen
allowing you to type with just one thumb
or finger or use the new swype keyboard
feature then you can pinch with two
fingers again to bring it back to the
full keyboard so that was everything you
need to know about multitasking and
apple's new ipod OS if this video helped
you out make sure to tap that like
button and click the circle above to
subscribe thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]